ein buch deshalb legt ihnen meine
kollegin uta kennt drei favoriten ans
herz bald sind ferien
nix tun
entspannen das leben genießen zeit haben
endlich einmal lesen wonach mieter sind
steht einen dicken schmöker eine kurze
polemik und einen bericht aus einer
stadt wie irgendwann im wasser versinkt
reiseerzählungen versetzen mich immer
sofort in urlaubslaune die strengen
frauen von rosas alba sind betrachtungen
aus venedig notiert vom schweizer
schriftsteller matthias zschokke 2012
lebt der für ein paar monate dort
zschokke ist ein widerspenstiger der
literatur der blick auf sein umfeld ist
oft über kritisch in die stadt venedig
verknallte sich auf den ersten blick
trotz der touristen interessanterweise
ist man überall mehr oder weniger allein
alles ist überschaubar aber alles auf
seine weise von überzeugender grandezza
und dramatik die ganze stadt ist etwas
für theaterliebhaber
jok gesagt alles auf was ihm unterwegs
begegnet jeden abend hat man das gefühl
schon wieder ein tag weniger in diesem
traum schon wieder einen tag versäumt
morgen muss ich es besser machen
ich will alles sehen alles riechen alles
essen trinken wertes bücher kennt weiß
dass er auch ein nörgler ein stärkerer
sein kann
doch genau diese eigenschaften
reflektierte auto hier selbstironisch
ich lese das gern die strengen frauen
von rosalba erscheint anfang august nach
venedig eine reiselust ist jetzt richtig
geweckt doch noch hat der alltag mich
fest im griff
mein digitale alter vor allem das
provokante sachbuch das kapital bin ich
von hannes grassegger ist ein aufreger
er zeigt auf wie wir alle ständig
persönliche daten ins netz liefern
und wie facebook google und andere
unternehmen damit sehr sehr viel geld
verdienen
wir gehören uns nicht mehr
wir sind digitale leibeigene
das internet wird von privaten
unternehmen geführt trotzdem ist fast
alles gratis
das problem ist dass wir überhaupt
keinen zugriff und keine verfügungs
rechte haben zu dem was wir sind
wir können nicht über uns selber
bestimmen das erinnert mich an die
situation im mittelalter als man uns
landschaften oder boden gegeben hat
damit wir darauf arbeiten können heute
geht man uns plattformen und die ernte
die kriegt jemand anderes daten sind das
neue erdöl materie ist nichts in der
post internet realität ist das internet
kein separater raum mehr sondern
integral klassikers schlussfolgerung die
zukunft ist digital
selbst wenn wir smartphone und computer
entsorgen der digitalen vereinnahmung
entkommen wir nicht besser wir lernen
dass für unsere zwecke zu nutzen
es ist relativ einfach wir müssen uns
eine art rüstung anlegen
sozusagen unsere daten verschlüsselt ins
netz senden so dass sie für andere
dritte für außenstehende nicht
verwertbaren nutzbar sind dann sind sie
verschlüsselt und als zweiter schritt
vermieten wir den schlüssel unsere daten
sind also in zukunft eine einnahmequelle
schöne neue welt jetzt brauche ich erst
mal wieder ein echtes buch 1 zum
anfassen 1022 seiten der distelfink
es ist die geschichte des 13-jährigen
theo der eine symbiotische beziehung zu
seiner mutter bei einem museumsbesuch
zeigt sie ihm ihr lieblingsbild der
distelfink des niederländischen malers
carel fabritius einem rembrandt das ist
ungefähr das erste bild das ich jemals
wirklich geliebt habe sagte meine mutter
gerade befangen beugte ich mich vor und
schaute mir das bild an das schicksal
reist mutter und sohn auseinander
in seiner aufregung spielt der junge das
bild
es wird zu seinem tröstlichen begleiter
theo muss von nun an ohne eltern
aufwachsen
das misslingt zunächst gründlich drogen
und kriminalität gefährden seinen weg
das gemälde das er stets versteckt in
seiner nähe hat wird zum symbol der
hoffnung eine heldengeschichte
unsentimental und liebevoll erzählt
lesen ist so aufregend
doch es ist sommer und ich brauche
dringend eine erfrischung
viel vergnügen beim schmökern
wenn sie jetzt voller leselust sind und
sich ganz sicher